Show me the explanation from Quran. Show
me that.
>> It says explanation it's a detailed
explanation of everything. The detail is
about the laws. No, it says everything.
No, no. Everything is about the laws.
No, it says detailed explanation of
everything, not of everything about the
laws. It is the same verse as the laws.
But the other verse you said okay.
All right. So, let's see if it says
everything about the laws, okay?
>> [music]
[singing]
[music]
>> The name of God. For what? For
everything.
>> the Quran.
To explain the Quran. Yeah, but the
Quran says that it self explains
everything.
It does. No, no. You take it It doesn't
say that. It doesn't say that. It
doesn't Even during Prophet Muhammad's
time, people go to him to explain to
him. Yeah, but the but the Quran says
that That's why we said you he said all
you in Quran is about Prophet Muhammad,
which is not correct.
>> I understand. It doesn't make sense.
[laughter] I understand. I understand. I
understand what you're saying. It
doesn't make sense. So, this this
I understand this but this is so this is
the issue. Like I understand everything
you're saying. You're saying that you
know the Quran says this thing and then
Muhammad and then Muhammad explains
things, right? I understand. Everything
in Quran I understand. something in the
Quran related to Prophet Muhammad. Well,
so this is where I
this is where I disagree. Okay. Cuz I
disagree that the Quran says that.
Listen to me. Listen to me. It's the
whole book of Quran. Can I continue?
Well, you cut me off.
I want to understand. One more thing.
Okay. Go ahead.
>> [laughter]
>> I'll listen to you.
Okay.
I agree.
>> Okay. That's the
I got you.
I understand.
I understand. I understand. Okay.
Let me respond to that.
Yeah, let me respond. Okay. Go ahead.
Okay. Thanks. So, I understand what
you're saying. I don't want you to think
that I don't. I hear everything that
you're saying, you know, but so this but
this is the issue he's bringing up,
okay?
The issue he's bringing up is that the
Quran makes clear statements that it
itself is a detailed explanation of
everything. That it itself explains
everything. So, he's saying he's saying
So, I got it. I got So, so he's saying
he like he's not not understand what
you're saying. He said the Quran what
what you guys are saying
is going against the blanket state the
blanket statements the Quran makes when
it says it itself is clear and
explained, okay? Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. I I understand. I understand.
Okay. Okay.
explain or you have any question to the
Quran
please go to the Prophet Muhammad. The
Quran doesn't say that. Okay. I open to
Okay. Okay. Okay. I open to you. Okay.
Okay. I open to you the book. Yeah,
yeah. I want to I want to see the book.
It's in Quran. I I might be wrong but
Okay. Let me Let me see. Let me see. Let
me see.
It's okay. It's okay. It's okay. Let's
not get him up away from this one.
It's okay. We're we're planting planting
seeds. Planting seeds.
It's okay. It's okay, ma'am.
It's okay, sister.
So, you're about to show a verse where
it says if you have question the Quran
go to Muhammad real quick.
So, what
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, the chapter and verse is the
chapter.
Uh women 59. Chapter
Chapter women 59. Chapter women
Uh four. Chapter four.
Okay.
59. 59? Yeah.
59.
Okay.
All you have All you have believe obey
Allah and obey the messenger and those
in authority among you. And if you
disagree over anything, refer to Allah
and the messenger if you should believe
if you should believe in Allah and the
last day. So, so do you see the cut?
It doesn't say if you if you question
the Quran then go to Muhammad. If you
guys
For
So, so if you if you it says obey Allah
and obey the messenger and also obey
those in authority over you. If you guys
if you guys have a dis meaning the
scholars, right? And their leaders?
Okay. Okay. Got you. Okay.
Oh, so you're Shia. Yes. Okay. Okay. Got
you. Got you. Okay. So, okay. So, that
obey those people that's in authority,
right? That's success that succeeds
Muhammad, okay? And then if you guys
have disagreement, refer back to
to them. Right? So, it doesn't say that
if you are in question about the Quran
or then to go back to Muhammad.
It doesn't say that.
anything. If you have any issue With
what? About what? About what?
Right if you
But but I I got you. So, this is talking
about disagreements, right?
Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> I I'm with you. I'm with you. So,
disagreement. I believe so can we agree
that like a disagreement that you can
have with somebody is different from
maybe a question that you might have
about the Quran? Because you could say
you mean Prophet Muhammad or you mean
Jews or you Christian. That's why we
disagree. Yeah, but but you
I understand. But
Yeah, but you but you
Yeah, but us having a us having a
disagreement is not the same as I got
you.
The Quran does.
No.
No, it doesn't mention the Quran here.
Yeah, the verse doesn't mention the
Quran.
Yeah, what what what does that mean?
How to you go to God?
Okay. So, when you obey Allah and obey
the messenger means that So, when it say
obey Allah means follow the Quran and
you're saying obey the messenger means
follow Hadith.
What? Like when it says obey Allah, how
do you obey Allah? Like uh how do you
know that you're obeying Allah?
Okay. So, Quran. Okay.
I got you. I got you. And then it says
obey the messenger, which would be
obeying Muhammad. How do you do that?
I know, but
I know, but how do you So, so is that a
like that person doesn't stand anymore
now?
So, you can only obey Allah now, not the
messenger.
I understand.
Okay, good. So, when you say would you
say the Hadith the Sunnah is a way that
you obey the prophet?
Okay. Got you. All right. That works for
me.
Okay, good. Okay, good. So, now when it
comes to explaining the Quran, right?
So, not just an a disagreement you might
have with a brother or a friend,
right? So, to explain the Quran, if
there's something in the Quran that's
not explained, where do you go to get
the explanation?
Muhammad. How?
You're saying Hadith, okay. So, the
issue that what you're saying you got to
go outside the Quran to get the
explanation.
I got you.
Okay.
So, all I got you. So, these so these
sources are outside the Quran that you
get the explanation, right? So, here's
the issue.
The issue is that the Quran says that
you get the explanation from the Quran.
You don't need to go outside.
It says explanation it's a detailed
explanation of everything.
No, it says everything.
No, it says detailed explanation of
everything, not of everything about the
laws.
You said okay. All right. So, let's see
if it says everything about the laws,
okay?
What the
Chapter 12 verse 111.
6115. No, not 6115. Chapter 12 verse
111, brother.
What is that verse? In other verse it
says it's about the laws. No, it
doesn't.
All right. Show me that.
I'm going to give you 6115 doesn't say
that it's about the laws. 6114.
12 111.
Yeah, that's the one. But you cannot
take one verse and leave the other. Say
that again? You cannot take one verse
and leave the other. I agree. Yeah.
No, I agree.
Oh, not for explanation. It didn't say
that.
No, it said if you have a disagreement
if you have any disagreement. Okay. So,
Okay. So,
And and who does it say to go to if you
disagree?
No, it doesn't. [laughter] It says go to
the people that are authority.
No, it doesn't say that.
Brother. Brother.
In chapter four
No, no. Listen. I'm not I I hear what
you're saying. I don't want to be
disingenuous. I'm going to take it in
context like you said. I'm going to use
the all the verses together. Look.
That's that's all the verses the same
thing, brother. Come on. Look.
All you who believe
obey Allah and obey the messenger
and those who are in authority.
If you differ in anything amongst
yourselves so not in the disagreeing
if you dis differ amongst yourselves in
anything refer it, right? I got you. So,
refer to Allah and his messenger and
I'm sorry.
Allah Allah
refer to Allah and his messenger. If you
I'm sorry.
Um
Oh, there it is. Thank you. Man,
goodness gracious.
If you if you believe in Allah and the
last day that is better and more
suitable for the final determination,
okay? So, you
Yeah. I understand. So here's my issue.
Our issue is is that
You obey Allah obey the messenger got
it. Obey those in authority we get it.
If you differ refer it back to Allah and
the messenger. Now you don't have that
but you have the sunnah and the Quran
right now, right? If you have
differences to solve these differences
or whatever. When it comes to the
explanation of the Quran let's say this
too. This can this can I agree that this
can go into differences that you might
have. I agree, right? However, the Quran
says that it itself is a detailed
explanation of everything. So so I so
even if I were to grant Well, it says
it's not just about justice and it's
about everything.
Okay.
Right?
Well, we go we refer to the Bible and to
church history to see how these things
were discussed and handed out at the
councils.
Of course there's differences so you
know
I don't I don't know. There's
That's true.
But our
our point is
Listen.
Can can I tell you why this is not
analogous?
Brother, can I tell you why this is not
analogous? It's like it doesn't match
the situation. The reason why it's
different is because our the Bible
doesn't claim to be a detailed
explanation of everything. It doesn't.
So but the Quran does. So that's so
that's so that's where that's where it's
different for us.
No no no brother, there's multiple
verses that say that in the Quran.
Yeah, it says everything.
So is that a contradiction?
So would that be a contradiction then?
And why? What do you mean? Yeah yeah
okay. So so
We're we're talking about the the the
Quran being [music] detailed and
explained, right?
About everything.
It's detailed about everything.
Now why would there be a a
a a misunderstanding
or a difference if the Quran is supposed
to be detailed and explained?
It's a good question.
Okay, it's a good question.
Right now we don't have prophet.
The Quran is complete?
No it's not.
>> [laughter]
>> No it's not. You need the Hadith.
So you don't need the Hadith?
Do you need the Hadith or not?
Do you need the Hadith? For what?
For anything. For anything? Yes.
There you go. Thank you. Okay. So my
friend basically and we're going to end
this cuz it's getting cold. Yeah. The
Quran is not complete because you need
and you admitted that you need the
Hadith to give you the explanations even
though Allah already says it is detailed
explanation about things.
But it's not but it's not complete.
It's not just about the Quran.
It's about stories about
So
When you say that the Quran is a
complete book
What do you mean by that?
We're listening we're listening now.
Okay. So when it comes to
So you're saying that when it comes to
the Quran if they have disagreements in
the Quran it's because Allah is testing
them.
Okay.
Okay but okay this is
So the so the issue is with me is that
So so the issue with me is that okay. So
Allah
there's disagreement with people who you
know are reading the Quran because they
are being tested by Allah, right? To
believe or disbelieve. So that's why
even though the Quran is supposed to be
clear
there's it's not clear for some. Is that
what you're saying? It's not clear for
specifically the disbeliever?
I I so
So I I I hear I heard your point. I
understand your point, right?
>> [laughter]
>> But he he he understands. That's the
point. HE UNDERSTANDS IT.
>> [laughter]
>> SO ALL RIGHT SO so we so we so we
understand we understand your position,
okay?
So so we understand your position.
>> [laughter]
>> So we so I got you. So we understand
your position, okay? So this is where
the issue for the issue comes still.
Okay. Last one all right. Last one and
this is it. I got you.
I got you. I got you.
I got you. Last one is it cuz it's cold
for us too.
So
I got you. Here's here's the problem
with us, okay?
When we read the Quran
it's not because we don't believe in it.
It's not because you know we have some
like something against the Quran.
We're reading it openly
right? With a critical with a critical
mind. Like we're using critical
thinking.
And we see things that we see Quran
makes very clear blatant statements like
what we're talking about. It's a
detailed explanation of everything. We
see verses like what you showed that
obey Allah and obey the messenger and
those in authority over you. If you have
differences go back to the messenger and
Allah. We see these clear verses, right?
Very clear statements. There should be
no diff no confusion about that, right?
The issue is is that when we read the
Quran
and we hold the Quran to what it says
it's a detailed explanation of
everything.
To be to to have to go outside of the
Quran it's [laughter] a
>> [laughter]
>> So so when when there's when there's
details missing in the Quran
if you have to go outside of the Quran
to get explanations or details that
shows that these statements the Quran
makes are not true when it says it's a
detailed explanation of everything, you
know? So like I can understand if the
Quran just said it was a detailed
explanation I can understand you know
there could be things that are
explained. There could be ambiguous
things. Things that are you know not so
clear. But when it makes the statement
absolute it's a detailed explanation of
everything that's when it's like okay
that's a problem because it's not. You
need to you need out you need outside
sources to help.
Your name? Avery. Avery? Yes. Issa.
Issa. Nice to meet you. Yeah, nice to
meet you.
>> [laughter]
[laughter]
>> Okay, your point is good. Okay.
Yeah.
How many books do you need?
Well well
Shoot.
Yeah yeah you write everything, right?
No I
I agree with you. you. It makes sense
the the the translation only. Well, how
do you explain it to yourself? Doesn't
make sense.
That's why I'm telling you this verse is
taken out of context. Okay, it it's
explained something and Quran have the
other verse to explain it. That's the
other verse
you know just the way it's to explain
something and this verse explain
something. The other verse said to you
if you if you disagree in anything or
you want anything to to to be explained
go to the prophet. Okay. During prophet
time people go to the prophet. What if
the prophet doesn't explain something?
During his time? Yeah.
Why what reason what the reason? Well,
like for example
let's like the crucifixion for example,
right? The crucifixion of Jesus. He's
the Quran says it was made to appear
that he was crucified, right? Now
Muhammad doesn't talk about this. He
doesn't explain that what it means, what
happened, who made it appear so, what
happened was he replaced or was it an
illusion that Allah like placed, you
know, he Muhammad doesn't explain it. So
right so this is like a big mystery. But
this is like history. You're talking
about like if you talk if you said
prophet Muhammad didn't say it. This is
like you need a historian to go read all
the the the book of the history written
or maybe you find he he talk or not,
okay? Because we didn't But no one but
no one has the ex like there's so many
different like nobody knows.
>> Yeah, but I mean the point is to say he
didn't explain it. We don't know. Maybe
he explained or maybe not. Why we need a
historian to go all read all the book in
the world written during this time in
the period or go back in time in
history.
>> But but notice Or go back in time by
time machine and see the prophet said or
not. Do you do you see my my do you see
my point? My point look cuz even if I go
with what you're saying, right? If I go
with what you're saying that okay, if
there's something that's unexplained in
the Quran, go back to Allah and his
messenger. But if Allah and his
messenger don't have it explained, then
we're in the mystery and then we're
we're still have something that's not
explained.
Prophet Muhammad during his time could
explain everything to them. Except the
crucifixion. That's that's one of the
things he didn't. But but we were me and
you weren't in during his time, right?
How do you claim that we he didn't say
it?
>> The Sunnah not even
>> Even the Sunnah is history. Sunnah not
all of it correct and it's history. It's
people written by people. It said
someone said something that's something,
okay? It's like the book of Ruth.
It's like history, okay? Someone wrote a
book about history and that any other
book. We don't know if
all I did that have all the details but
because it's a
1,400 years ago. Would would you agree
So so you would agree that what we have
so far if we wanted to get Muhammad's
explanation, all we have to rely on
particularly when it comes to Muhammad
is the Sunnah, right? To get his
breakdown and his explanation of things.
>> is very very detailed and I have a
thousand you know hundred thousands of
books. I agree. Now Maybe millions of
Exactly. Now now now watch this. There's
so there's so many Hadith. Not one of
them explain what happened at the
crucifixion. Not one. I'm I'm I'm out of
the book.
If you want I can give you. Yeah, I
would I would love But I mean I need
library I mean Islamic library to go and
get it. So there's
there's a book where Muhammad explains
what happened at the crucifixion? I what
what book is that? I mean a lot of
books. If you want I can give you but I
don't have it right now, okay? Okay, I I
I've never seen that. part of history
and it's explained very detailed. And
even you know there is movie, you know?
No I know I
>> [laughter]
>> I'm not talking about the crucifixion of
Jesus. What happened at the crucifixion?
Yeah, since you read it what happened?
Uh but it was
with Judas. I got punished him and he
made him look like he was crucified.
>> that. No, it doesn't say that.
Where where does Muhammad teach this?
Not Muhammad. Muhammad said to his
people, okay? This is the story, okay?
And people after him they wrote it. But
some part of it they don't it's not like
you know during Muslim it's not like a
big issue to write it down. But Muhammad
wasn't there.
It would have I would have to have been
revelation from from Gabriel
and Muhammad would have written that in
Quran
with the details. Or somebody would have
Yeah, somebody. If if prophet Muhammad
write a book like 1,400 years ago He
didn't write anything like that. Okay,
listen.
He taught people to listen, okay? To to
to
to write. Ali wrote a book, Fatima wrote
a book and and other combine and they
have a book. But you know politics will
not leave you a book and even the book
is staying maybe 100 years and it's it's
going to be I mean damaged. You you
cannot have like all historian book
here. I mean give me a book Bible 2,000
years ago. No, but you have Bible 2,000
It's not that's not an argument. That's
the point. You want you want what?
Authentic book from like you know 1,400
years ago?
>> No, not necessarily.
No no not necessarily cuz I I understand
that even the Hadith manuscripts don't
go back to Muhammad's time. Yeah, but
that's the point. I know but they they
these are narrations that people get
from Muhammad, right? So what I'm saying
is is that do they have a narration
where Muhammad it says we heard the
prophet say and then what happened at
the crucifixion? Prophet Muhammad we we
call in our religion. Our religion is
city of knowledge, okay? He has
everything everything. Not everything
during his time and after his time and
before his time. And the gate of
knowledge is Ali. Okay. Knowledge
knowledge the whole world. Okay. That's
why Islam conquered almost like you know
about huge part of the world from desert
of Arabia. Okay, it's not you know you
think it's
someone if you go to Arabia and make a a
new religion and try to conquer the
world right now will or will change it
an idea in the in in in like in Arab
world. You will never succeed in that.
That's why this is like a miracle to go
like a land in Arabia where they are
like at that time maybe they know they
have nothing and they know nothing and
change them to conquer the world.
How? I You need a miracle. I would say a
miracle even politics it's not easy.
It's very very difficult. disagree but
what how does that help with this what
we're talking about?
>> That's the point. Point is
prophet Muhammad city of knowledge,
okay? We have we think not we think we
believe he's the most knowledgeable
person
ever. And he wrote not about his time
and even after his time. But the books
we don't have it because
either damaged or politics.
>> Okay, so
let me make sure I understand you
correctly. even after him Ali is the
gate of knowledge. He wrote a lot about
So
let me let me try to make sure I
understand you.
during his time after time or before his
time. I got you. So I'm going to try to
see. So are you saying that
there is probably some information that
Muhammad had and shared that that we
presently don't have right now.
>> A lot almost of it. Okay, and you're
saying that the crucifixion the details
of the crucifixion might be among those
things? Everything everything. Not only
because crucifixion in Islam is not that
big it's not our religion, you know?
Yeah, but it's the Christian religion.
Yeah, yes it's made for you but for us
it's like you know okay It it was big
enough for Allah to touch on it to say
hey guys it didn't happen, right?
Okay, so this this is what this So let
me let me be clear what I'm what I what
I'm asking for, okay? So if So if I'm
granting you your position that if
there's something that's not explained
in the Quran when it says it's an
explanation of everything, part of that
is going referring back to the messenger
and referring back to Allah, right?
If
um the Quran doesn't explain what
happened at the crucifixion, then
Muhammad would explain what happened at
the crucifixion, what it means that it
was made to appear and what actually
what took place so there's no confusion,
right?
So there would have to be a narration
from Muhammad an authentic narration
from Muhammad where he's breaking down
Surah 4:157, right? Um
if that if that doesn't exist if that
doesn't exist, then we don't have an
explanation from Muhammad where he's
breaking this down and therefore we're
lacking an explanation that the Quran
mentions. So the Quran is lacking the
explanation and the Sunnah is also
lacking the explanation which then
explain quick and the Quran it touch
stories
uh let's say in Arabic we call
um how would you say or like
tell me in summary, okay? Mhm. Don't
don't take too long. Quran doesn't take
too long to explain anything. It just
touch the story and the main point you
understand it, okay? This is the main
point. This is it. This is how is it.
In Arabic we call this is the the
absolute eloquence or I say you don't
like go in details on writing book
because But that's the Listen. Listen.
Okay. If you write this detailed story,
how many books you need to write about
the crucifixion?
>> If you're talking about just the
crucifixion, all you might need is just
four books. Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah. Okay, four books.
Maybe just one. Yeah, four books. How
many prophets we have? So many prophets.
If he talks all the details about our
prophet, it's going to be long. I I
wrote I wrote I wrote the book for it.
It's very long.
Let's keep it let's keep it focused on
the crucifixion. If you didn't need a
you don't need one book. We have it in
Shia and Sunni we have the same story
about the
crucifixion of Jesus. Very detailed,
okay? You can read it. From from
Muhammad? Yeah, from Muhammad and his
companion. Very detailed.
So I need it from Muhammad. Not think of
it from Muhammad. Yeah, but Quran is
mentioned it's mentioned
story shortly that it was you know
which is they were be
how do you say it?
Is
doubt? Yeah, in doubt like someone else.
This is the short, okay?
It was it was made to appear so. story.
If you give me summary of it.
Joseph story? Yeah, you can write it in
one page or you can write
100 I mean
10 10 books.
>> Trust me I I know what you're saying. I
know what I say but because that's why
the point. The summary is you can talk
to the prophet Muhammad and Ali and
there is in Shia and Sunni there is. But
the see that the Quran
the Quran is No, this is where it's
lacking for me. The Quran doesn't claim
to be a summary of all things. It
I know but it claims to be a detailed
explanation of everything. So if the
Quran is missing details and
explanations, you're saying, "Oh, well,
we could just get it from the prophet."
Okay, if we go to the prophet and we
don't find it anywhere in the Sunnah,
then the details and explanation is
missing from both Sunnah and Quran.
And therefore, the claim here in both
verses, 4:59 and the other verses we
were showing, it shows that there's
there's a lack of detail and explanation
that the Quran promises is there. The
detail is about the laws. About the laws
No. Yes. Yes, it says No, it doesn't.
Yeah, I'll show you. No, it says
everything. Everything about the laws.
Everything about the laws.
But say the other verse, if you disputed
anything, go to the prophet. Yes, and
when I go to the prophet, if if there's
no answer on the crucifixion, then what?
So, I
I would like to see that. I would like I
cuz I've never seen this before, so.
Yeah.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. It's very detailed.
>> [snorts]
>> Mhm?
Yeah.
You want Sunni or Shia?
Um what what do you rely on? Any
anything where we could see where
Muhammad talks about it.
Do you know of any Hadith where Muhammad
talks about the crucifixion, like he
explains what happens?
A mass hypnotism happened.
Is that what Muhammad says?
>> No, but but this is what they what it
clearly
the rituals. Okay.
It's like a
>> They killed him, not crucified him, but
also wanted to be there.
That's not the Hadith. Yeah. Look for
the Hadith itself.
It's kind of a general
Yeah, from from what I know, brother
Issa, from what I've I've seen that
there's no Hadith where Muhammad
directly is speaking about
the crucifixion, like he's explaining
what happened. I I haven't seen it
before, you know. I can I can refer to
you I
I've read before so many and
through Ali and companion through other
companion. Want to get my email? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, I'll I'll I'll give you my
email
and um
if you find something, you can you can
email it to me and I'll check it out.
Have a good night, man. It's nice to
meet you. talking to you, okay.
>> [laughter]
>> Very nice. Yeah. Very respectful. As as
as as Sunnis need to learn from you,
okay.
>> [laughter]
>> Sunnis does good.
Sunnis does good.
Oh my god.
Logic.
>> [music]
[music]